no okay think back to when I play
Bigfoot with Shawn we had a little joke
about the possibility of big face big
face can be a woman to your face can you
imagine if there was a monster called
big face a big face is not a thing as
far as I know we made him up but this
game proves that big face is real
exceptionally real oh okay oh I gotta
get in the truck well what did I just do
oh that's looking backwards okay so I'm
in a swamp they see they're gonna be
Shrek or it's gonna be this mythical big
face you know this is surprisingly well
made for what might be originating from
a stupid joke or it might actually be
terrifying hello what is what is all
this hey I do the screaming here what
the hell was that was that big face oh
but Phil you're proof footage of big
face Oh remember big face has to be
directly in the center of the camera
sites in order to record it for any
footage account oh whoa pressing app
missing are will start recording holding
are with the camera off will replace
your batteries okay all my drain in my
bed
that's a spicy spicy lightening hello
something wrong with that Gator what Oh
God is this actually like a scary
experience here is this actually gonna
be spooky or there's this all one big
mean because at this point I can't tell
which is which
okay hi big face
hey big ugly stupid face hey big face
wherever you may be I'm gonna film you
Wow holy crap Oh
oh my oh my god okay big face ain't no
joke big face no joke oh my god
big face [ __ ] big face big it's real
big
by lightning so brightening hi what are
you what are you you okay oh oh okay get
off of me I didn't know that was the
bear trap how do I you're breathing what
are you why is this covered in bees
where's big face I didn't think that
this was gonna be any kind of a actually
spooky experience I thought this was
gonna be one big joke but apparently not
apparently big face is Ricky still play
around hi big face oh my god what do I
do about that oh god your face is too
big oh it's too big it's too big for me
to handle how do I get away from big
vision if you get me with another
goddamn bear trap I'm gonna lose it
right so I'm just gonna bring this job
okay that's not breathe okay changing
battery out so glad I'm doing this for
the dare that my friend made me go on
just because I lost a bet this seems
like a perfectly logical reason to you
know whatever I don't know which one of
these giant circles this big face you a
platypus
so what are you supposed what do you do
what do you do do you gotta hide behind
a thing just weird
I'm gonna guess I have to break line of
sight on big a big face I love trees but
I love trees what good don't wait around
here if I see big face I'm gonna get him
in my camera and then I'm going to sell
you call big face
hey big face okay kind of change the
battery so I only got a little bit of
proof on that one but that proves that
breaking the line of sight or fos for
you gamers out there is what dudes the
thing oh god oh my god
okay that's fine
somehow a 20 foot tall face snuck up on
thank you somehow I don't know how but I
jag antic face in the woods managed to
sneak up on me don't know how but it
happened all right I think this is about
as good as place as any to have my
little standoff here maybe this rock
makes its face rude this is the skeleton
of your family big face did you kill
them or did they die of natural causes
who's okay okay okay got a little bit a
little stay mindful is that him over
there that's him so on no I stopped him
that's a mouse that ain't big face I
would know oh you over there Oh what
does he run away when I does he run away
when I start recording I think I might
have found the solution what is this
what is this this is mushroom house Oh
oh you're not that makes the opposite of
sense okay whatever I'm just gonna wait
from a dude I hear him oh god that's not
him okay you want to run that by me why
was there a big roar who's roaring who's
roaring and how was he able to sneak up
on me am I just not seeing him before he
gets also where's he going also he seems
to run away when I record him so I think
that's this got to be the strategy right
I just got to go get up for you big boy
that's not you oh there's two sides to
this swamp I didn't know that
Oh gonna run out of batteries here Oh
putting it away recharging big face big
face what series doctor God's gotcha oh
yeah you better run away
all right yeah you coward
I'm gonna chase you down now your big
face is gonna be on the front page of
the big paper sloppy mid-face II fairly
not I don't like this I don't like this
damn Wow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah I got your oh I
got a face full of you where you going
big boy got your number now it's just a
matter of whoa hey bud what was that
what the hell was that what what
happened what just happened I had him I
had them I don't know what the hell just
happened
this is honestly terrifying I don't know
what's going on I don't know what I'm
looking for where yet where you had a
big face thought I heard that over here
oh ah I got you got you got oh yeah yeah
frou-frou frou-frou proof yeah you run
yeah you run oh you can't sneak up on me
not this time
okay your number now I can't believe
this is honestly terrifying I I can't
believe that at all I cannot but whoops
dude dude yeah yeah yeah yeah oh I'm
halfway there halfway there bud you're
gonna be a bit more aggressive aren't
you little pitter-patter douches damn it
dude so good god damn it okay I'm not
gonna let you beat me big face I'm gonna
kick your ass I'm gonna rule this swamp
I'm gonna buy it I'm gonna put some dirt
in here I'm gonna play the whole forest
you hate that wouldn't you oh I'm gonna
totally transform his ecosystem and
there's not a goddamn thing you can do
about it what da [ __ ] out of here
windows update oh my god [ __ ] are you
not gonna go away Jesus cry you now now
you're really now now is the time when
you're gonna be a dick oh [ __ ] off
oh yeah I can't even where's my mouse
where's my mouse no don't open it up oh
do not schedule oh my god let me
schedule it holy [ __ ] oh my god I can't
move my goddamn out I have to get out or
are you [ __ ] kidding it's about to
it's like counting down you [ __ ]
[ __ ] lemon I swear to god there god
damn it
don't [ __ ] alright let's go hon big
face shall we okay good haha oh god no
oh wait wait got you got you got ya
Oh what was that
did I just run into a ghost
this game is messing with me I swear
this game is messing with me
it is absurd this game is absurd
ridiculous absurd ridiculous
ridiculously absurd ah ha ha ha you
thought you could run well I mean you
did run but whatever ok so he can spawn
in any direction is the thing so if I
want to get the goodest proof possible I
gotta let him get kind of close what is
that what what is that what is what the
hell Oh what what what whatever
oh no no I will destroy you annihilate
you I will tear down all the things
you've ever loved that I will break you
Bobby please I'm really gonna get him
this time I see you got him oh he got
real close then but I still got him
I probably shouldn't let him get that
close
ah god damn it okay it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
whoa ah you are more than halfway there
you can't hide you cannot wait was
heaven did I see you
that's your ghost oh my god is that a
ghost
what is that oh my god what oh god oh
god I'm low on battery there's not a
good time not a good time big face do
not okay Oh am I losing visibility or is
this just the way the game is always big
face oh god okay see that's right this
tense I don't know why I'm really
stressed about this and I know I
shouldn't be it's just a big face what's
he gonna do gobble me up
we're and know where the tiny little
body is can handle all of me that's too
much meat on the bones no no no no no no
no not now I knew this was gonna happen
big face
okay
okay guys saw that one what is this
oh nothing oh it's nothing funny it's
it's it's I it's nothing unless this is
big faces like home maybe it's his cave
I don't know maybe I'm too far at the
edge of the map I'll go back to the
center big face big face I'd spend too
long it's been way too long since I saw
Oh God oh my god okay I don't know what
the ghosts are about Madoka where is he
come on where is he
I'm losing it I'm losing it I'm starting
to look no that's not even starting to
lose it where is he stop get away - stop
running toward me go i freakin platypus
I don't know where he is he's just gone
go away oh god big face oh I'm really
losing it now oh god I'm gonna lose it
I'm freaking out man I'm freaking out Oh
big face is watching me from somewhere I
know it
big face is watching me I know this to
be true my eyes have never been this
open before man I've never been this
awoke weird where did he go where's my
face I'm really starting to lose you
guys I'm starting to lose it
oh my god serious
he's right there what's he doing he's
stuck
oh he's stuck oh all right so I got a
yeah it's it's some all right yeah it
sure is something
oh my god it's something oh good god oh
do not get unstuck you stay stuck you
stay stuck forever okay I'm just gonna
go to my truck you're gonna be out of
luck I'm gonna go do not come back
please just let me go and we'll call it
a day
hey at least you're not big-ass that's
the last person I would like to meet in
these woods - imagine - great heaving
cheeks peering out from behind a tree
trunk thicker than all get-out thicker
than the Mississippi River thick is your
dreams oh yeah like - undulating
balloons of molasses just clapping round
to treat flap flap
the last sight you ever sees those two
huge cheeks clapping your head in Twain
smush you like a grape in between those
paving thick um's
anyway sorry just you I'm glad you're
not big asses all I gotta say about that
I'm kind of letting my guard down
because I'm pretty sure he's stuck they
don't know where my truck is I'm
assuming it's just at the far end of
this where I've went and I don't know
why my truck would be over here Oh what
what what oh okay I've not if that was
that existed so yeah maybe down this way
oh there's another side of this tunnel
how big is this
what topic is this place
how big is his face where excuse me
where's my truck with please eyes eyes
just want my truck please please Oh Oh
God
okay alright I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry please forgive me
Oh he met okay though oh my god are you
gonna are you gonna actually catch me
like
[Music]
the hell is happening here oh oh oh okay
the longer he's awake the faster he will
chase oh great you can send them away by
either interacting with them or
recording him recording increases his
speed gained over time okay I don't like
that right there right there Jer
I don't know what the electricity all
prepare to be can't go through this cave
that makes sense okay cool
good good in a sense I don't know where
he is
I don't know where he is I don't know if
I can't see him or something
is that the deal I don't know I don't I
look I'm out of battery now I didn't
mean go into your pocket dimension so
I'm just gonna back out bygones is
bygones sorry for awakening you I
apologize you go back to sleep I will
just leave this dare not worth it I'm
gonna go away so wha yeah that is that's
big face what I don't know if this just
spawned out of the conversation I had
with Sean but holy crap that's a really
weirdly in-depth game for that really
good if you guys want to try to beat
this or find other secrets there were
things just in the caves everywhere why
I don't know but there were so check it
out link in the description it's free so
check it out thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see more
scary games that I played link is in the
description or in the suggested videos
over there if you have not seen a heist
with markiplier yet go check it out
links in the description put a lot of
work into it
mean the world to me if you saw it don't
check it out you won't regret it
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]